Julian Assange lived in an embassy in
London for seven years on a spring day
in 2012 he dressed up as a motorcycle
Delivery Man dyed his hair with colored
contacts in his eyes and even put a rock
in his shoe so he would walk a little
differently than normal he was sure that
dark government forces were after him
and he showed up here at the embassy of
Ecuador in London Ecuador granted him
political Asylum which protects him from
being arrested as long as he stays
inside the walls of this Embassy oh and
by the way this is an actual footage of
Julian Assange we actually hired an
actor and like did a reenactment anyway
Assange lived here for seven years
occasionally going out onto this balcony
to address his supporters and continuing
to run Wikileaks eventually his hosts
got kind of sick of him and kicked him
out in 2019. it probably didn't help
that Ecuador's new president was also
the subject of embarrassing leaks the UK
police immediately arrested him and the
U.S is requesting him to be sent to the
U.S to face charges for all of these
leaks that he published still in a
British prison right now though likely
not for long but wait what was the
actual crime here that gets to the heart
of the story stay tuned